[Music]
this is star talks sports edition we're
going to talk about sensors in this
episode more on that in just a moment
first my co-host Chuck Nice Jack hey
what's happening professional stand-up
comedian you do stand-up clubs right
pretty regularly
yeah I mean uh that's the only way you
can be a comedian okay I guess
also a Gary O'Reilly Gary former Soccer
Pro and a commentator we're here my
co-hosts all right Gary you you
this is one of yours again I I just know
the title of the show sensors but you
don't have to take us into it where you
come where it's coming from and where's
it going so start us off so the show
begins
in space it's a with a suit that has
been designed for the Planetary
Exploration of the Moon and Mars in a
galaxy far far away a Time long long ago
yeah perhaps perhaps
um we meet someone who not only worked
on the space suit in question but who
wants to give robots a sense of touch
now this is going to press a button for
you Chuck but oh my God
who the hell idea was it to do this show
this means us getting into soft robotic
technology we will explore smart
garments that are fiber optic based and
therefore more photonic than electronic
that I don't have a problem with that's
more haptic oh that's okay that's that's
more haptic augmentation than it is
giving a robot a sense of touch okay
that's helping me be able to touch
things in a better fashion I'm cool with
that because it helps me uh human being
okay okay so I'm going to try and give
you a soft Landing here Chuck we'll see
if you get a few bumps along the way
um right we also meet another co-founder
who is part of this team that is driving
forward this particular project in so
many different directions the particular
technology has multiple medical
applications I think computer gaming
wearables they'll go there it's the
fashion item and yes you guessed it it
has Sports applications as well in
particular it'll be technique analytics
injury risk reduction
biodata feedback such as breathing
analytics and much much more and you're
gonna love this Chuck the the the inner
house husband that you are it's also
washable
oh oh how thoughtful exactly right let
me let me introduce our two guests we'll
start with he later is CEO and
co-founder of the organic robotics
Corporation graduate of Cornell
University in mechanical engineering
we'll also meet Dr Rob Shepard associate
professor at the Sibley School of
mechanical and aerospace engineering at
Cornell University studied at Harvard in
George whiteside's Department of
Chemistry and chemical biology where of
all things he realized he was going into
Robotics and no surprise to see that he
is CTO and co-founder of the organic
robotics Corporation Neo our guests
welcome guys Eliza you should say your
name sort of we cannot just like that
and your last name please go ahead
so so what is the Smart suit thing what
like what is a smart suit we all we'll
have these images of Neil and Buzz on
the moon with these big bulky suits as
they're skipping along but they don't
look very Nimble and they don't look as
comfortable as perhaps they could be I
don't know so what uh so our image of
being in space is that all right so how
are you going to change this
well I think uh I have a collaborator
and a diazartias at um Texas A M and she
makes she's into bioastronautics she
wants to make spacesuits that astronauts
want to wear that they can baby perform
more like athletes here on Earth and
what Buzz had to do was fight against
pressure in the suit to Ben bent his arm
and uh one of the things she wants to do
is make mechanical counter pressure
suits which is more like what you see on
the Star Trek movies
conformal stuff and it's squeezing your
um your skin to keep that pressure
differential from you know popping you a
little bit so I hadn't really thought
about that because if I have if because
I'm in in basically zero pressure
atmosphere right so you have to put
pressure back on me so that my blood
doesn't boil or weird things don't
happen right right and so with that
pressure I don't have
I don't have I can't move it in my
joints right because there's pressure
everywhere so you need some kind of
mechanism to get through all the joint
parts not only my elbow but my shoulder
my fingers yeah so there's two ways to
do it one is to use the same suits are
being used today and augment the force
so that you can get help fighting
against that pressure
or you can remove the internally
pressurized suit all together and just
have like a compression garment that
squeezes you and then your joints are
less hindered to move
kind of like is it kind of like I
shouldn't say kind of like I'm asking
like in a flight suit when you uh that
squeezes your lower extremities so that
the blood isn't draining down and it
pushes everything up so you don't pass
out yeah it's pretty similar to that and
it's like a so a giraffe actually has
something like an evolved G suit so they
have a high pressure from their heart to
feed blood to their brains but when they
lean down to drink water
um their heads don't explode because
they have you know fascia and skin
that's good that squeezing it
drafts 101 their heads kept exploding
right by the way that is a great name
for a bar the exploding giraffe head
come drinking our word a hole
so the more so you can be like dress
skin the better Elida what does organic
have to do with any of this when I think
of Material Science and I think of
Robotics biology doesn't ever enter my
head here so
um what is the organic part of this
well I think that's actually a better
question for Rob because we just took
his lab's name and then added
corporation instead of labs so that's
why I record what called organic
robotics corporation instead of organic
robotics lab but you know we're now
going for light lace which is the name
of the technology which we can talk
later but you can talk more about the
organic stuff it's not food everyone's
like oh it's a food organic means USD is
certified yeah your organic robots in
the in the organic aisle of Whole Foods
right because that's what's going to be
next uh it's just organic chemistry
using chemistry to make
um robots and now peop people better
um than you know machined aluminum or
and bolts and and stuff like that
um soft robotic technology what does it
actually mean and and am I right in
saying it's kind of like biomimicry here
are we or am I on the wrong paths yeah
I'm glad you gave me an opportunity to
do that because I think we're evolving
towards where
um the company started and you know my
lab sort of has taken its own Direction
so I started off at Cornell in
mechanical engineering taking what I
learned at Harvard making soft robot
machines
um and what they are is just um
Continuum deformation smooth
deformations that don't look like hinged
robots from the you know that you think
of from the 50s they're made up of
materials like animals they move more
like animals
but everything we made at Harvard was um
what's called feed forward in a robot
like you issue a command and then it
just does it but it can't respond to the
environment because it doesn't have any
sensing
um so what we did in my lab here at
Cornell was to add
soft sensors to the system touch sensors
so it could feel what it's interacting
with and then respond to it make a truly
feedback controlled
soft robot
um and so then it can feel and respond
and look like an animal
um and we use Optical like guides
instead of electrical sensors for a
variety of reasons and Elida was in my
lab making these sensors for robots and
then decided why don't we just use these
on people instead and then that's when
the company started and that's
um the lab continued to make stuff for
robots the company makes stuff for
people
okay by the way that's the plot of a
disaster movie right with a brilliant
engineer say let's do this on people
right
and everything turns for the worst so
how do you how do you scientifically go
from knowing as as our fingers can touch
and sense to being able to interpret
touch and replicate it for one of your
Technologies
it's very basic we cannot do it nearly
as well as organisms do there's a
variety of mechanoreceptors in our skin
that respond to different pressures and
different frequencies of pressure
um temperature
um and this is a lot of information that
we have to encode and then send to our
brains and we only have a limited space
to do that with so we encode this
multitude of information into electrical
signals spiked through our neurons and
then our brain interpretses that
interprets that information and then
sends commands out one of the reasons we
use Optical systems in my group instead
of electrical ones you can encode more
information optically than you can
electrically
hence the urge to lay fiber optics for
for media Communications right Paul said
high frequencies but you also have phase
information color information and
intensity right
um all of them can represent a different
mode of touch feedback and you can
encode that into one signal and then
send that to the computer which then
sends the response
using light instead of electricity does
that mean you're immune to the
electromagnetic pulse that the aliens
will send down and [ __ ] our
civilization is that right it is a big
it actually is a you know it's it's a
very important point you bring up we're
immune to electromagnetic interference
so you can you could potentially use
these things in like MRIs
um or other places where magnetic fields
can penetrate our electric field so yeah
they're in a cockpit there's a lot of um
places and be resistant to aliens
every time the aliens come they shut off
your electricity yeah which I am P yeah
everybody knows that everybody knows
they're gonna first first first uh line
of attack is the EMP that's right and
then they're just like clearly they're
using some type of optic system
we've underestimated them
unfortunately we still have to convert
it to electrical signals so there is in
the end yes in the end right right right
yeah oh well so how how accurate is this
fiber optic
ability so because I'm I I I it's as
Neil said it's media it's it's TV it's
it's a telephone connection but you're
using it in a totally different way
so you're obviously using how are you
interpreting how that light changes
in terms of the results that you then
decode and interpret
we use uh color and intensity right now
and we make our sensors so that they can
change color when they're stretched and
they can change intensity when they're
stretched
stretching can be linear or pressing or
something like that but um we're not as
sensitive as something called a fiber
brag grading Optical waveguide
um which is they're sensitive to
um hundreds of nanometers of movement
um we are sensitive to tens of microns
of movement that's like a human hair
diameter but we think that's sufficient
for robots and people and by making that
trade-off we can make our systems much
cheaper
um and and much smaller right it seem
Overkill if you had nanometer
sensitivities that that's there's
nothing we do in our life that that way
yeah like that I think that was a
nanometer off
no wonder I missed that pool shot yeah I
just think people want to know an
enemies of billionth of a meter so right
yeah we're not but a human hair that's
something we can see that means
something to us so we can feel that we
decided that was a good Target
um because yes exactly what we said you
can feel that you can't feel an enemy
right right of course we're going to
take a quick break but when we come back
more of the secrets of this emergent
technology of these spacesuits that will
basically replace humans and we'll all
die I'm pretty sure is that where this
show is going Gary dude no I I did
Envision a happier note
okay all right so we'll be right back
start talk sports edition
we're back StarTalk sports edition we're
talking about sort of robotic suits for
all manner of applications that not only
that we've thought of but maybe stuff we
haven't even dreamed of yet we've got
two mechanical engineers turn roboticist
here we've got eladas and Rob Shepard as
our guests so let me start off uh ilada
tell me in my notes Here we say
something about light lace and fiber
optic Tech what what precisely is that
so light place is the name of our
technology it's a fiber optic sensor but
unlike other fiber optic sensors it's
soft and stretchable and that's why
we're applying in to humans because if
you're wearing a wearable device you
don't want to have bulky or
uncomfortable fibers or Electronics on
you so
um that's our technology is soft and
stretchable fiber optic sensor and it
measures things like motion it measures
your missile fatigue it can measure your
chest extension respiration heart rate
so basically it is a way to track your
vitals as well as your biomechanics
while being comfortable whoa because you
know this reminds me I haven't heard
this reference lately but Chuck Chuck
and Gary might remember but there's
something
uh
there's a there's an expression that
says uh it was all over you like a cheap
suit yeah right and a cheap suit doesn't
fit you well right but and but it needs
to in order to look good on you but if
it doesn't fit you well you move one arm
and other pieces of the cloth move and
it climbs up your neck and so so what
you're saying not to put words in your
mouth is that previous suits were
wearing you
whereas now you get to wear the suit is
that a fair characterization of this I
think we can say that and it's like one
of our selling points is that you wear
compression garments or like tight
fitting clothing to exercise anyways so
just gonna feel the same way but now
we're making them smarter
right right so everything and a little
lemon is is snug fitting on everybody's
body who buys clothing there so now it's
going to know all about you is what
you're saying how is the data retrieved
like I mean what is it how is this
speaking to whatever uh it's speaking to
so that we get all this information yeah
it's pretty similar to other wearable
devices we have a phone app like an IOS
app you can download and it speaks to
the device via Bluetooth so you can just
look at yours measurements real time all
right stop your exercise and just log in
and see how you did cool so when you've
put the fibers through fabric
is there an optimal pattern
for those fibers fibers to be woven into
or is it basically a simple grid system
there is an optimal pattern because our
fibers are made so that only parts of
the fibers are sensing and we want the
sensing mechanism to be wherever we want
to sense so if you want to sense your
tricep the fiber has to be the sensing
part of the fiber has to be woven into
or
integrated into the Garment in that
specific area Okay elada I want to
monitor my I want to monitor my belly
fat so would you put sensors
we've done something where we place our
sensors around the abdominal area
axles when you're doing certain
exercises so what we could do is you
could wear this every day and it will
eventually tell you if your belly got
larger in size or it got
um smaller in size or it's stiffer when
you touch it you know you could we could
also measure
um the response back when you touch it
so if it's soft we can measure that if
it's no longer soft we can measure that
snow definitely
are you able to weave this into Fabrics
that are very slight high performance
say like for a dancer a performer an
athlete or do the fibers and you said
they're the sort of diameter of a human
hair are they necessary to be in thicker
more heavy weight
Fabric or can you really go into
lightweight we can't go into lightweight
but just a clarification the fibers we
currently make are not as thin as human
hair it is possible currently they're
around 800 microns
um in diameter and we prefer actually
thinner fabric for them to go into
because like especially if we're going
to wear it outside then summer you don't
want to wear something thick but we
could do either
so right now we're talking about
Diagnostic and if I'm getting ahead Gary
then we'll skip it go for it go for it
um instead of listening to the body
which is what you're doing
is there an opportunity to tell the body
what to do
so we can tell the human that they need
to do something about it but we're not
trainers ourselves so we're gonna have
to rely on a trainer to look at the data
and say oh okay when you do this
training five times in a row 10 minutes
intervals this is how your body reacts
so maybe you should change this and then
they can take more data and see how that
change affected that oh and then you get
real-time data
multi-dimensional data there that's
excellent I think Chelsea wants to know
about actuation and how you can modulate
the force
um the sensors are hard enough so we're
going to do that and then there you go
you're like okay I got you you're like
you're in that side you're in the Sci-Fi
uh mode there too there are people
working on it it's very hard my lab is
working on it but it's for a company
it's very difficult but but if you could
then it could be like like the force you
you can go on your app and just change
what the body the human body is doing in
response to your wants and needs yeah
that's why that's one of the things the
bioastronautics application is for it's
the sensors for measuring the
environment and they're also built-in
actuators into the um mechanical counter
pressure suit to help them perform
better in in right right right wow that
is crazy so go back to what uh Elida
just mentioned when you're talking about
we have this tranche of data and then we
offer this reservoir of data
is it possible one at one point you'll
be putting personal trainers out of work
because that data will be uploaded to a
AI cloud and it will make those
determinations for you oh yeah I like
that I like that
um I mean I think this can go yeah we
can say that for many other jobs like a
lot of technologies have the potential
to take over or complement it we want to
be on the side of complementing the
physical uh personal trainer or physical
therapist or a coach but we're not
trying to take anyone's job I see what
you're doing there I see what you're
doing there Elana because you're like
look these personal trainers they're
pretty large people and they're very
very
we don't want to piss them off we don't
want to piss these guys off
so the thing here is major major league
sports has already taken note of
lightless and you've Congratulations by
the way uh were awarded an NFL award for
fifty thousand dollars first and future
award for your product
um what was it that they saw in light
lace that made them so enamored the new
China Light pun intended on that for us
we get a lot of light pants for sure
um you know there are a lot of
selling points of our product I think
one being we can measure different
things at the same time instead of
relying on like three devices you can
just use one shirt that has light lace
and it can measure both your respiration
your muscle fatigue and your emotion so
if you want to do this currently you
would need three different devices so
maybe like a strap that does respiration
you would need sensors that go in your
muscles to do that and then you'd need
camera based systems for motion tracking
we combine all of it I think there's a
lot of value in that and because we're
an optical based technology we have
higher sampling rates so if there's any
consistency between each movement we're
more likely to measure that compared to
any other sensor so I think that was
another reason why they were interested
and lastly I also add this this is a
short like we have some shorts behind me
but it doesn't have to be a shirt and
for NFL for example leggings lower body
those are also very important and it's
very very simple for us to just
integrate the sensor into leggings or
lower body garments and measure that as
well so there's a potential to measure
full body
gloves shirts leggings socks shoes it
doesn't depending on what the person
wants to know we don't really have a lot
of limitations when it comes to the form
factor how how well do you think Rob
your light lights will perform in an NFL
game when it comes to contact because
Google pressure sensors here well yeah
and that it's contact and weather
conditions as well because you're you're
playing in every single conceivable
weather condition in the AFL plus you're
sweating and you're sweating your fiber
optics yeah and you're having a car
collision on every single place so you
put it right as they describe it yeah
they describe the the impact of every
tackle as though you're in a car
accident every single time there are
rapid decelerations for sure
um we can capture those as elata
mentioned we we can sample a really
really fast think of this as a wearable
ultra high speed motion capture system
that can also measure pressure
interactions
um it has to be worn close to the body
so the temperature variations aren't
that big a deal because your body's
going to sort of maintain that it's so
important temperature right it's not
electrical so you can get it wet
um there's not really that many
environmental sensitivities for using
Sports and they can handle High
pressures there
um they're soft but they're very tough
and toughness means you could absorb a
lot of energy before you break
so you know what this sounds like with
if you if if you have a full body
a lace is everything right neck
everything and then you go up with your
with your IOS app
that's a tricorder yes isn't it
man it's great isn't that a tricorder
the tricorder
measures everything that's going on in
the body without cutting you open that's
kind of what you've done there we don't
have to just use our sensor we can fuse
lots of different sensor information
right
um your Apple watch uses photo plus
eismography which shines light in
measures a reflected light out right and
from that they can you can get a lot of
things you can get systolic pressure
yeah
um you can get respiration rate
um
but what what those systems are missing
is also you get your aux numbers too
right I mean yeah
the Pulsar right right the amount of
signal processing that goes on to get
all that information from that little
bit of blood flow is incredible yeah um
what is not there is the the amount of
air inhaled
um which is extremely important
you can you can calibrate that by seeing
the expansion and contraction of the
chest cavity can't you we can right so
yeah that's part of it so this is better
than a tricorder without a doubt you
have exceeded 25th Century technology
right here
if we take a step back you said this is
more accurate than the high speed
cameras now we've done shows in the past
discussing high-speed cameras and it was
exclusively on baseball and in
particular pictures are you now being
co-opted to bring this product to
baseball bear College be it minor league
or major league and are you working with
the pitchers if you can if you can
outgun a high speed camera
um you've got to be in there surely yeah
we're definitely baseball is going to be
our beachhead Market we think there's a
lot of value there because they move
really fast especially pitchers and even
with human eye or motion capture camera
based motion capture systems it's hard
to capture that because everything
happens in less than two seconds so if
you take a camera based system and you
get maybe like four data points
throughout the pitch we can give you
let's say 400 data points and that's
right so you don't have to interpolate
between the pitch you can just look at
the pitch and you'll be able to see oh
Pitch one versus pitch 10 at this
millisecond you behave differently and
maybe that's why you're not pitching as
fast or maybe that's why you're gonna
get injured well more importantly well
not more importantly uh just as
important is form for everything yes
form is all of sports it's all about
having that form become a a
non-conscious second nature muscle
memory muscle thank you yeah muscle
memory you guys are actually able to
teach muscle memory
yeah
um so there's a study in 2015 by the
first author I think is Wilk and uh what
they showed is that um
after they sampled 300 baseball players
um the ones that had the greater
shoulder Mobility were four times less
likely to need Tommy John's surgery so
if you can help them increase their
external internal rotation
um uh degree of Freedom then they can re
increase their lifetime with some
reasonable probability so teaching form
is really important and
um these these things a pitch takes two
seconds but the initial accelerations
take milliseconds and it's obscured so
if you are trying to capture it with
external cameras those cameras need
you really and these are we're talking
about 10 000 degrees per second shoulder
rotations if you're capturing at a
thousand samples per second you're under
sampling and you really need to be
sampling at you know maybe 10 times the
rate for a non-periodic motion
um there's something called the Nyquist
Criterion which says twice but that's
for a periodic motion for something
aperiodic like this you need to think
even more than that just to clarify so
if you have something that repeats you
can and you want to measure it
you can say how many data points on this
repeating feature do I need to
characterize exactly what's going on and
that's your Nyquist frequency you're
describing but if it doesn't repeat you
don't you can't
right you all bets are wrong doesn't
repeat no right that's it and and that's
a really important point we think that
pitching inconsistency is a huge
variable that cannot be measured right
now to to what matters this is a
hypothesis and we need to validate it
but we think by measuring faster you
will reveal that the accelerations are
faster than are being measured right now
and then if you can't re if you don't
know it and you can't repeat it you
can't get these consistencies and
further the torques generated in this we
think are being radically under reported
um and that that can result in injuries
and you wonder why can't people tell
when these injuries are going to happen
you should know the soft tissue loading
conditions that are viable but people
put pictures enter themselves all the
time you know this is even outside of
sports yeah I'm just thinking about
these applications
um for rehabilitation not of athletes
but I'm talking people who have
catastrophic injuries yeah where they
have to learn again how to walk
everybody thinks that we walk you
learned how to walk you actually learned
how to do all the things that you do
that you take for granted your brain is
running you know a process that lets you
do these things and if you damage your
brain then it doesn't work anymore you
have to relearn it this kind of
Technology could greatly reduce the
amount of time it takes to do that yeah
definitely rehab applications Physical
Therapy applications it's just a way to
get feedback if you know if your brain
can't get that from your sensors you can
use external sensors like light lace and
see that feedback on an app and then try
to behave that way and see how change of
behavior or change of the way you're
moving change of your motion is
affecting that light lace reading uh one
of the scenes here is that uh we have
sensors we can feel our ourselves but we
have imperfect memories and biased
memories and so being able to digitally
think of course
I constantly think I'm six too
um so but anyway we have uh we have
these if we can digitally record this
information then we can go back not just
with ourselves but with other sports
scientists and physiologists and help
you with less bias interpret what's
happening and and physical therapy a
great application where I'm horribly
doing physical therapy I've never
successfully completed a physical
therapy regimen
um and I think if I was reporting my
information to the doctor they would be
able to call me out I'm not actually
doing it you know and help me improve
faster
and I just want to highlight for
something because you just said it and I
want to make it clear when you refer to
the acceleration in the picture just
what's going on the ball is going from
zero miles an hour to a hundred miles an
hour in a fraction of a second
all right and you know from you know the
the pitcher gets ready and then they
[ __ ] their arm and as their hand goes
forward they're accelerating the ball
from zero to 100 miles an hour there's
nothing we do in life that accelerates
that fast right in a car your head would
snap off and roll backwards so but
there's not only that there's also
there's some rotation of the wrist
there's a lot of sort of joint action
going on there and you capture all of
that I'm very impressed by what this is
and what it can can do for us thanks for
saying that it's really a lot of who who
identified that each Head Market and
I've been fascinated with it and yes in
two seconds 100 miles an hour but
how fast is it does it get you know in
the first eighty percent of that
velocity how does it what time duration
does it achieve that and we think it's
um and this is backed up by some other
data
um that it happens in like very soon in
the in the pitch and then this is also
why people with longer arms are viewed
as better pitchers because they can
apply that acceleration for longer
periods of time
um and but or they can do the same speed
um by by uh accelerating a slower rate
over a longer period of time which can
preserve their joints for longer but we
have examples of pitchers who defy that
um and then how do they defy that like
Pedro Martinez was not a tall pitcher
for the Red Sox or or he might have been
sub six feet Tim Lincoln Lynn's income
was 510 I believe and and if you look at
his biomechanics he he extends his most
pitchers will pitch over something like
80 35 percent of their wingspan they'll
move that but he did it like 125 or
something like that you know there's all
kinds of stuff to learn for biomechanics
and injury reduction and and these it's
been it's great that systems like
um what do they attract men and
um Hawkeye trackman
all of these motion capture systems that
are out there now and some that are some
are even getting higher in sampling
rates
um are providing all this information
but being able to have that unobscured
at rates I mean there's really nothing
limited we could potentially do millions
of samples per second
um versus they all use cameras they all
use cameras
you're at the actual Source yeah exactly
exactly there is not a sport that will
Embrace detail
detailed data like this like baseball
yeah which is and the GMS are gonna love
you they'll eat it up they'll eat it up
we gotta take a quick break when we when
we come back we're gonna find out what
the future of all of this can be because
just to have this capability oh my gosh
there there are problems solutions that
people didn't even know they could
attain once they had X you know until
now that they have know that they have
access to this technology we're gonna
hit that up in the third segment of star
talk sports edition we return
we're back StarTalk sports edition film
of the future of monitoring what your
body is doing on the inside but you're
doing it from the outside with this
magic material that are two guests have
pioneered and I think I perfected your
names here so you have
iliata Elijah
you like yeah okay Elijah
you moved to an A minus from B plus okay
thank you and Rob Rob Shepherd uh you
guys are mechanical engineers and but
you're into robotics you're into robotic
monitoring uh The Human Condition
on and sports has a huge benefit from
this particularly which we're spending
time on which we spent time in the last
segment the the rate at which you can
gather information on something that is
moving fast and is non-repetitive is
without precedent here so what it what
are your best applications today and
what do you see coming down the pike
tomorrow
yeah I'd say as we briefly discussed
earlier the best application Brighton uh
would be baseball and pictures
specifically because of the high-speed
motion they go through
and how often they could go through that
motion which usually results in injuries
it's very common to have a tummy jaw
surgery there but whether we see this in
the future like I said we want to make
full body garments not just shirts or
not just straps but also leggings shoes
socks really anything you want to
measure or any area you want to measure
and we want to apply not only to sports
but also provide medical benefits like
clinical application Physical Therapy
we've looked into robotics of course and
even car seats you know we had an
interest in measuring Comfort levels
driver attentiveness did you forget your
child it happens a lot in the car so hey
hey it only happened twice
and the third time it was on purpose
no judgment look when you dis you later
when you discuss those applications
outside of the sporting realm I'm
sitting here wondering and I'm not a
computer gamer but this sounds like it
is absolutely set to walk itself into VR
and AR now as that universe come to you
yeah definitely I'm I'm surprised I
forgot to mention that but the why is
there are two different routes we think
of where when it comes to arvr training
so we can do training so instead of just
seeing a reconstruction of your hands or
your body in the VR environment you'd
also receive feedback on how much force
your appliances if you're learning say
medical training you need to know how
much exactly to push when you're doing a
surgery and you could get that
measurement with our sensors if you were
wearing them and then gaming the same
thing instead of just seeing your body
on the VR environment you can
get feedback on how much you're pushing
how much you are pulling something what
that results in inter like in the gaming
environment so it makes it more real
yeah so now your this is information
flowing in One Direction do you have the
ability
to send information back so you know if
if I'm I'm talking for corrective
purposes so if I'm throwing and your
um fabric is saying hey man what you're
doing right now is you're stressing
right here in this part of your rotator
boom and if you continue to do that we
know when that's going to happen but at
the point where it's happening is there
something is there a signal that can be
sent that lets me know oh I just did
that and then if I don't feel that oh
that's I did it right that type of deal
yeah there are a couple different ways
we can do this one of them being we can
send the information back via uh
different light patterns so our sensors
glow oh we can make them not glow or we
can make them glow in different patterns
so maybe having them glow three times or
glow having them glow red could mean you
are about to get injured you should have
stopped we could have them glow green to
mean something else and the other way to
go with this is have the app tell you so
if you have your phone or iPad or the
device in front of you it could also
just tell you there it has great
feedback truck we'll build that in there
another thing we do is put uh put a
little vibrotectile thing in the Pod
like I said yeah this has an electrical
portion too which is located a small pod
located depending on you're gonna make
you're gonna make garments glow and
change color you're gonna sweep up
you're going to sweep up the team Market
you're going to get the 20-somethings
you're going to get the 30-somethings
and the 40-somethings you still think
they're 20 something not to mention all
the ravers that will go into a club and
get rid of their light sticks so that
they can just use their shoulders
that's it that's what I'm saying
I gotta I gotta ask you now I have and
what you're doing is is incredible but
now is there a dialogue between yourself
I find what you're doing entirely
credible it's not incredible it's
entirely credible thank you that's great
yeah I stand correct oh sit correct it
are you now in discussions with
biomedical Engineers the work that
biomedical Engineers are doing trying to
map and code signaling the neural
signals how long before you guys talk to
them and you come up with something
together this is where we both work on
wearables and Robotics which is
Prosthetics
um and so measuring signals from that
outside world and transmitting it to our
body through electrical impulses is
something we have worked on in the past
and are continuing to work on but it's a
such a long slog and um well electrical
impulses that you feel on your skin or
that you somehow impart into the brain
uh that you would impart into sensors in
your skin which then would
send that information to the brain right
yeah and it's almost the same thing
right because your brain is sensing the
rest of your body yeah and we've worked
on the hardware part which is making a
prosthetic hand
um that actually has pretty good and it
had it's lightweight High Force it's
quick
um
feedback controlled and everything
um and it's quite simple at least for us
to add the capability for that Hardware
to Output electrical impulses that could
be then used so something I saw that
you've been working on is embodied
Energy Systems and I've seen a little
tiny little video of your soft aquatic
robot which I would call a fish but no
it's being called a soft aquatic robot
so talk to me about embodied Energy
Systems because that's I think that's
going to talk Chuck out okay yeah uh
yeah so if you look at uh the best
example the general purpose robot today
I think is spot from Boston Dynamics
that yellow quadruped that walks around
yes
um so we can do that for about at least
the last time I I heard is 90 minutes
um is that the one that opened the door
two of them opened the door and the
other one walked through yeah there's
actually just now that have hands and so
it can yeah it's really useful in a
general purpose way we've had robots for
a long time but they're very specific
this one you can tune to do lots of
different things
um but I can only do it for 90 minutes
where if you look at something I like to
use a walrus as an example
um a walrus has a ton of fat on it but
that fat is multifunctional that you can
a walrus can operate without recharging
for you know weeks at a time
um and it can just sit still for you
know theoretically months at a time but
it can do has all kind of agile things
it can it could outrun you it definitely
me
um they're fast on land they can swim
they do all kinds of things and they can
do it because they're using their energy
in a multi-functional way it's not just
a battery pack that isn't adding
anything else to the system so what
we've decided if a walrus is chasing me
on the ground on the land
It's not catching me I would never lift
that one down okay
yeah they can charge really fast they're
pretty fast they're like no think of a
hippo in the water you would think big
fat ass HIPAA will never catch me but
you put a hippo in the water those
suckers are moving like a little
motorboat I know I'm just saying like
the way they never live it down the next
day or willpower would uh chase me down
on land okay
that's funny so we've decided to make
liquid that can be used as hydraulic
fluids for moving robots around also as
the battery so the liquid has electrical
potential that we use to power the robot
so we've called it robot blood
um and now we recently published
something called the robot heart which
is a stretchable pump that behaves it's
electrical it's not the same way it's
our body works there's no muscle my
heart is electrical too though that's a
good point Thank you for yeah that's
great I'll start using that the
stretchable soft pump that it also pumps
the same blood that powers the heart
um and then gets gets everything moving
so the energy is doing a lot more than
just powering the system you're creeping
me out I told you yeah
you're creeping me out because now you
got robots that have a heart and they
got blood and they can feel and they and
they don't need to be recharged and
chuck chuck if it bleeds we can kill it
that's a good point yeah yeah that's it
you've built a synthetic vascular system
into your robots as well so if it if
this fluid is
is it energy dense it's just not just as
a hydraulic it's is it creating how is
it created it's got to be a conductor
hydraulic is it just connect is it
kinetic or is it chemical or is it both
it's electrochemical so the hydraulic
liquid has electrical potential in it
and then we pass it by electrodes which
then turn that electrical potential into
electricity that's very clever thanks
and Chuck any any
any
um liquid will have a
uh have that property not the electrical
properties but it'll have the the
pressure properties so right yeah uh
he's just being clever and double
dipping that's what I'm saying yeah yeah
it's like our circulatory system you
know it does many different things it
does many different things so you know
uh it's it's making use of one thing in
several different ways which that's the
nature does yes yeah so yeah that's very
very clever thank you and uh and by the
way stop it
all right
is that is there anything you could tell
us about where you like to to
look at going in the future what your
aim is where your aim is well we in my
lab we want general purpose robots and
for that they need to be adaptive
unplanned environments space exploration
is a great place for that um operate for
long periods of time without needing to
be recharged um also ocean exploration
so we're focused on Ocean exploration
robots and space exploration robots but
to be adaptive you need feedback control
it's not just Vision like you know
there's um I don't think there's an
example of an animal that only uses
Vision I mean touch is an important part
of adaptivity so that's why we've spent
a lot of time uh making a robust adapted
which these with these stretchable fiber
optic touch sensors
yeah that makes sense because once again
talking about nature you know like so
many animals in nature use sensors that
we would never even begin to understand
well we would never understand them for
our use because we couldn't do it you
know even like something as simple as a
snake sticking out its tongue or or a
dog you know sniffing another dog's butt
you know they're really yeah no come on
let's be honest they they're not just
perverts of information no no no no no
Chuck Chuck the question for the ages is
if dogs can smell things like miles away
yeah why do they have to get within a
quarter inch of what to smell it okay I
take it back they are perverts
doesn't that mean yeah it's like hey uh
you know what Jim I know it was you from
a block away but yeah what the hell I'm
gonna double check get up in there
anyway
I knew it
so guys we gotta Land This Plane oh
before we do Neil I need a practical
answer
just how washable is it are we talking
one more two washes can I get a year out
of this can I iron it yeah
we're in my tests to okay be able to say
that but we've done tons of tests and
they survived the the electronics part
is fully removable so you can just slide
it out and then put it in the washer and
dryer but to be able to say if it will
last a year we need to test it for a
year which we haven't yet yes all right
okay as long as you don't mind me asking
cool now one last point I just want to
verify and I think it's true
um rob you were describing the limits of
the pitching
uh activ the pitching motion that would
put a picture at risk of requiring Tommy
John's surgery that presumably you don't
know any of this in advance you have to
teach
the system what will and will not be the
consequences of what someone does in the
system to then have a baseline of data
so that you can advise the next
generation of people on what the causes
and effects are of their problems isn't
that correct you need yeah don't you
need actual people to try this get the
Tommy John surgery and say oh here's why
you needed the Tommy John surgery that's
after the fact so that everybody that
comes later they can know it before the
fact yeah that's that's a we need to
provide a benefit
um that is not just on injury prevention
to get people wearing these so that we
can develop the probabilistic models
that will allow us to predict yeah when
these injuries will happen but there's
also the possibility that we can
analytically predict this based off of
again we think that accelerations are
being radically underpredicted right
based off of motion capture data and if
we can say that the acceleration is
actually you know more than 500
degrees per second squared it's 700 in
the first couple of milliseconds and
that'll greatly that'll change just to
be clear that's an angular acceleration
correct yes when you say degrees right
and uh that could end up with torques
that are you know 40 more than what
people think and like no wonder you're
you're you're tearing your um your
shoulder muscle musculature ligamenture
and you know not just the elbow although
the UCLA is what fails mostly
um but then that's because that
acceleration is being transferred into
that elbow no snap so we think that yes
we want a probabilistic model but maybe
along the way we can capture information
at high enough frame rates that we can
actually understand just from a
fundamental level of course you're
you're breaking your ligaments because
you're applying torques that are beyond
what they can handle
wow technique all right guys it's been
Delight to have you as a guest on as
guests on StarTalk sports edition I will
be monitoring your space going forward
and if you make new developments be sure
to come back on and talk about them
absolutely sports edition all right
excellent uh Chuck Gary always good to
have you there man always a pleasure as
my co-host this has been star talk
sports edition uh all about the future
of stuff figuring out what you're doing
inside your own skin For Better or For
Worse okay
I even kneel the grass Tyson your
personal astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]